καθεβανάληψην το το σύστημα τους και έουν ν αντλήσει στουχία οή έχουν κέρδι οι έχουν
ότι διπου ότι δλλονοοφελος άρα προσπαθούμε να είμαστεαναβαθμισμένα τα μετρασφαλία μας σε όλη την δημόσια
υπηρεσία αλλά και οι τράπεζες και οι οργανισμί και ιδιωτικός πτομία ζίνεται με άλλης σημασία
στους ιδιωρικό των ιδουρικών τομέα γενικά αλλά θα λέγω κίνδνωση είναι εκεί και πρέπει να
εμαυτε συνεχώς υπψιασμένι βλέπουμε ότι πολλές φορές κάποιαεταιρεία προσπαθεί να κάνει ένα βασμα της πλεξιωτερικό
σε κάποιον οφιλέτιιπό έχει μια οφιλί και έρχεται έναν ηλεκτρροτικών μήνυμα και λέει ολογαραεδούν μου
έχει αλλάξει αντί να μου βάλετε τα δέκα χι λιά ε υρώ στην αθιείνα ου
είνορατού υπάρποιο μου τα ελευτά στην τσεχία των τάδαλεογαργιασμό είναι εκεί που πρέπει ίνα υτή
υποψιασμένη ότι πιθανών υπάρχει κάτι υπάρχουν περιπτώσεις που εμβάζονται χρήματα σαράντα πείτα ιλιάδες κατόχει λιάτες
μια φορα αντί να εμβατούν στην αθεία βάστη αστη σεχία και αν είμαστε εντός ευρωπακής
ένωσης καλώςαν είμαστε ν εκτός ευρωπαϊκής ένωσης τοτε αρχίζοντα δυσκλά γιατί γιατί ι συνεργασία με
χώρες εκτός επρώπεις προπάντων ασιατικές οι αφρικανικές χώρες είναι σχεδόν ανυπάρκτι και υπάρχουν πολλού τησκολίες
θα σας κάνομια ερώτηση την οποία μου έκανε να μέναν η κόρη μου δεγάετο πρόσφατα
ήταν τα ημέελ τα πιλητικά στα σχολεία και ήταν φάνεηκε ότι αν κάποιος πιθανών α
πιηρωσα όπως με πεκι κόρημου γιατί κάποιος που είναι στηρωσία να θέλει να μην κάνουν
μάθημα τα σχολία στην κύπρο που αποσκόπουν αυτά τα ημέλ και δεν ήταν η πρώτη
φορά ήταν οι δεύτερη μέσα σε λίγους μήνες ίναι αυτό τι δ αφαινούν που υπαρατεβείδες
όλη την εμπρώπιανα δεευκρινήσω γαδιορωσία εργότερα μότα ποκάτι